Hello, my name is Bjarne Dacker.
And I am responsible for the Computer Science Laboratory
our job, that is to put research to work
and our main challenge that is
how to program large real-time systems
as efficiently as possible
and of the many experiments
we decided
that we had to move from conventional high-level languages
such as C, Ada, ???, C++, etc
into the world of declarative
programming
we also found out that the only way
to do that ??? to develop our own language
and the language
which is called Erlang
in this video, we'd show you
about the properties of this language
and how it has been applied in large prototyping projects
and also about the potentials of this language in the future
declarative programming languages
have several advantages over traditional languages
for example
programs in such languages
are considerably shorter
than equivalent programs
in imperative languages
here for example
is a program in C
and here is the equivalent program
in erlang
they also encourage
clear programming styles
for example
the object-oriented programming style
or the implementation of abstract data type
is simple in Erlang
up to now
declarative programming languages
such as Prolog and ML
have not been used
in real-time applications
so we have to add
a notion of concurrency
in real-time
for our language
we've also added
a sophisticated error detection mechanism
this allows us to program
robust real-time systems
declarative programming languages are of course also symbolic
and
we'll stop by showing you symbolic nature of the language
in a typical telephony application
Erlang is a real-time declarative programming language
but in order to do experiments
with such languages
you need more than just
a computer
you need a real world application
and real hardware
to run it on
let's going to our lab to see how we've done this
this application is based on telephony
we have programs in
an Ericsson MD110 PABX
this PABX as you see here
using Erlang
but that's not really quite true
because we've changed the
standard MD110
very very slightly
so that
it communicates with the SUN workstation
and the Erlang program we are going to be running
are actually running on that SUN workstation
no on the
PABX itself
this has been done by
connecting the hardware signals
through from
the PABX to the workstation
and vice versa
here is a standard Erlang environment
we running X windows on a SUN workstation
we have an Erlang interpreter window here
and an Emacs editor window here
ok let's just make a normal call
just to see the ??? system works
(ring)
hello, Mike
hello, Joe
system working?
seems to be
OK, fine
OK
right, we are going to do it again
and this time
are going to look at some of the symbolic information
??? available in the system while placing a call
I am going to dial Mike again
1 - 6 - 7
what we see here
is the symbolic trace of communications
to and from the number analyzer
it first received
message analyze 1
returned result get more digits
it then received request to analyze digits 1, 6
and again returned result get more digits
and lastly it received a request to analyze digits 1, 6, 7
it then returned
port 67
which ??? hardware address of telephone
and then I'll dial an incorrect number
1 - 6 - 9
here again we see symbolic trace of communications to and from the number analyzer
again it got request to analyze digit 1
and returned result get more digits
then it got request to analyze digits 1, 6
and again it returned result get more digits
finally (it returned the)
it got request to analyze digits 1, 6, 9
this time it returned result invalid
(as) as this number is invalid
okay, we've just shown you one of the properties of the language
that this is symbolic language
??? symbolic information is always available
and I like to show you another property of the language
and that is how we handle errors
and in order to show you this
??? I'm first going to make a
??? normal call as I did before
to Joe in this telephone
(ring)
hello, Joe
hello, Mike
OK, I'm now going to leave this call setup from this
phone here
and now I am going to make another
phone call to Joe on his other telephone
??? use this phone here
(ring)
hello
hello, Joe
OK, that's a ...
we have now made a call to Joe
I'm going to make a call to Robert
(ring)
hello, Robert
hello, Mike
??? now I have a ??? call setup to Joe and one to Robert
of course I can go back and forth between the two of them
hello, Joe
hello, Mike
hello, Robert
well, now I'm going to do something
which means that the system
goes wrong
what I'm going to do
is that I'm going to try and puts the
calls into a conference
so I press this button here
which should put them into conference
and as we can see by the screen
things starting to go wrong
we see here
that something has gone wrong
an error has ???
here is the original error
which caused all subsequent errors
it also caused those parts of the system taking part
in that error to automatically restart themselves
for example
here's one of the telephones
part in the call
which crashed
and was subsequently restarted automatically by the system
we should now try and find out what caused the original error
we see that something was undefined
we also see that it was the function m multi
in the module feature which was undefined
we should now go into the module feature
and try correct the error
we are now in the module feature
we'll try find the call to m multi
now I know there is a function called just multi
this seems like it could be a spelling error
we'll try correct it
save the file
load it again into Erlang to see if it works
we are now back in the Erlang window
and we'll load in the corrected module feature
and restart the system
to see if we actually corrected the error
let's see if Robert succeeded in fixing the error
I'll do the same thing again
first I'll make a call to Joe
(ring)
hello, Mike
hello, Joe
and I make a call to Robert
(ring)
hello, Mike
hello, Robert
now, I'll press the conference button
??? to see if it works this time
hello, Joe
hello, Mike
hello, Robert
hello, Joe
hello, Mike
hello, well it works this time
??? I leave Joe and Robert talk to each other
and go out to the conference
hello, Robert
hello, Joe
I think you managed to fix about them
yes, finally
you remember before we went into conference
we set up a call
let's see if that call is still running
hello, Mike
hello, Joe
OK, I finish this call
well what you see now is that this call was
totally undisturbed by the fact
we have had errors in the system in other calls
and we've reloaded part of the system's software
this call here still worked
and the interesting thing is that it would have continued to work
whatever state the call was ???
it could been ringing
it could been dialing
it could been between dialing digits
whatever had happened
calls in this system are completely independent ??? each other
??? error in one call will never affect
error, error in one call
will never affect the the correct operation of other calls
you've just seen
our language Erlang
and the telephony application which we run using Erlang
but in fact our application contains
many more features
what we've implemented is
hot number
warm number
short number
diversion
diversion on busy
911 emergency
black list incoming numbers
transfer
conferencing
directed call pick-up
call waiting on busy
call waiting on no answer
and intrusion
Erlang has been used outside of our laboratories
by Ericsson for a large-scale prototyping experiment
their findings agree completely with ours
programming in Erlang
leads to at least a factor of ten improve programmer productivity
Erlang programs are concise and elegant
in fact
they are about seven times short than equivalent program written in C
it's easy to write robust system in Erlang
and of course, all this leads to very short ??? times